so speaking of hospitals another 24
hours have gone by since our initial
coverage of Donald Trump appearing at
the hospital over the weekend without
Walter Reed knowing he was going to
supposedly just kind of get ahead on his
2020 physical there is now more
information and more context and it's
time to stop pretending that Donald
Trump was maybe not rushed to the
hospital for some kind of emergency
medical service Hillary Clinton didn't
have Parkinson's period that was a
conspiracy theory but Donald Trump does
appear to have had some kind of medical
incident that required him going to the
hospital when it was not planned if you
were a hillary parkinson's truther you
should be demanding transparency here
about Donald Trump's health we don't
need to get conspiratorial what we knew
yesterday was that Trump went to the
hospital over the weekend spent two
hours there we were told he wanted to
jumpstart his 20/20 physical and that
everything's fine we then found out well
Walter Reed Hospital had no idea he was
coming we then found out that no
president that we know of has ever
broken their physical into two parts
including getting a jump on it in the
year before the physical is actually do
we then found out that the press was not
it was told don't expect to see Trump at
all the rest of Sunday the press didn't
see Trump on Monday we have still gotten
nothing more sensible than the
completely unprecedented and again
unbelievable explanation that Trump he
had a free weekend so he said let's go
do two hours of medical testing at the
hospital but don't let them know that
we're coming the press corps still had
not seen Trump as of this morning
Tuesday morning since he went to the
hospital on Saturday Trump sending some
tweets during this morning's impeachment
inquiry hearings so this is not about
Trump is bad because he had a medical
incident I know I'm not insane I'm not
immoral I'm not unyk but the clear
obfuscation about everything has to stop
and Trump's health is part of that Trump
was rushed to the hospital and they're
trying to keep the explanation secret
they are obviously not telling us the
truth
Trump has lied about his health for a
long time he's lied about his height and
weight he's lied about his
cardiovascular health claiming you know
bogus letters from Doc
saying it's it's all fantastic now I've
gotten a few emails saying David this is
what we've been telling you they are
setting up either a resignation or
something that will be based on either
cognitive decline or failing health so
that Trump doesn't risk losing
re-election so that Donald Trump doesn't
risk an impeachment conviction
maybe there's no evidence that that's
what's going on right now all we know is
Trump is 73 he appears to be obese
although just shy of it according to the
height and weight numbers he's given us
although we don't believe them he lies
about his height he eats terribly he
doesn't exercise he might abuse uppers
he lies about everything why would we be
surprised if Donald Trump was hiding
medical issues the country does need to
know this is a real thing on which one
might decide to vote for one person or
another Trump knows it the people around
him know it and I imagine that something
is going to get out sooner or later but
let's not pretend that this is what
Trump's press secretary Stephanie
Griffin Grisham said which is Trump was
bored he didn't have anything going on
so he said let's go to the hospital for
two hours even though I don't need to do
this until next year it's not believable
it doesn't make sense let me know what
you think is going on make sure that you
sign up for our Thanksgiving promo on
Black Friday we will be emailing
everybody on our newsletter with just a
massive membership discount special the
last one of the year you need only get
on our newsletter to be notified of that
on Black Friday the day after
Thanksgiving go to david pakman.com sign
up for the newsletter it takes mere
seconds and then you'll get an email
next Friday with that info follow me on
twitter at des Pakman let me know what
do you believe is going on with Donald
Trump and the hospital visit and the
fact that he has as of this broadcast as
of right now as I'm recording this not
been seen in public since returning to
the White House on Saturday I want to
hear from you let me know on Twitter at
D Pakman leave a youtube comment one of
the day's sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card
to privacy calm then you can create
virtual credit cards that are linked
directly to your bank account and you
use those virtual credit card numbers to
buy things online which protects your
actual debit card so that it's not
spread all over the internet and one of
the best things about it is how their
mobile app and browser extensions for
Chrome and Firefox make it really easy
to use let's say for example that I'm
signing up for a david pakman show
membership in the credit card number
field I already see the privacy com icon
I just click it choose which of my
virtual credit cards I want to use and
the credit card number expiration date
and security code are automatically
entered I can put in any zip code I want
and I'm done and if you try to use my
credit card number that you just saw on
the screen it doesn't matter because
I've already deleted that virtual card
and that's the beauty of privacy calm
there are a ton of advantages to using a
free service like this for example you
can sign up for as many free trials as
you want then just delete the virtual
credit card you used and never worry
about getting charged for it it protects
you from getting hacked it protects you
when companies are hacked which happens
all the time it is all completely free
all you have to do is click the link
under this video to get started and for
a limited time they're giving everyone
in our audience $5 towards your first
purchase when you sign up using that
link